hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled uncover all hallmarks of
cancer with multiplex gene and protein
assays using luminex technology
this webinar is a part of the cancer
research and oncology 2021 virtual event
i am antonina salcido of labroots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminex for more information about
luminex please go to luminexcorp.com
now let's get started
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
a new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find the live chat
located at the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr segren
vodrana manager and product development
at the thermo fisher scientific center
of excellence for immunoassays in vienna
austria
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr brodrana welcome you may now begin
your presentation
hi everyone and welcome to this
presentation on multiplex gene and
protein assays using the luminex
technology to uncover all hallmarks of
cancer
as you know cancer research is one of
the most dynamic fields with various
focus areas that undergo rapid
development also driven by new
technologies while there's still demand
for reliable tools for comprehensive
analysis
to accelerate progress and further
support cancer biomarker discovery and
verification across key cancer research
areas thermo fisher scientific is the
only company to offer highly multiplex
assays for both gene and protein
expression on the luminex system
providing a flexible and quantitative
solution for research purposes that is
now also available in a 384 well plate
format for even higher throughput demand
so actually there are two applications
on one instrument platform that make use
of the xmap multi-analyte profiling
technology and are compatible with any
of the luminex instruments
while on the one hand in vitro chain
quantity ginplex assays with
incorporated branched dna technology
allow for accurate gene expression
analysis of up to 80 targets per well
directly from analyzed blood or tissue
homogeneous sample without the need for
rna purification procartiplex
immunoassays on the other hand enable
scalable and reproducible protein
quantitation with the simultaneous
detection of actually up to 65 targets
in a single sample of plasma serum and
other body leaf fluids
requiring only a sample volume of 25 out
of 50 microliter in the 96 well plate
and even less than the 384 well plate
format which is now also provided
particularly for the brocarda plex
platform as unique ready to use solution
with live last pre-dispensed capture
beads on 384 well flat bottom plates
which makes the workflow even more
efficient and convenient
of note these multiplex assets can also
be easily customized by either selecting
any rna transcript for the quantity
ginplex or by choosing from our broad
list of protein targets for human mouths
and other species
covering cytokines chemokines growth
factors but also other biomarkers
relevant for cancer research and for
many other areas of biology and interest
for cancer research on the quantity gene
platform a 50 plex panel is readily
available enabling the simultaneous
detection of relevant targets including
immune checkpoint modulators and immune
cell markers besides selected controls
as shown here to study cancer-related
immune responses on a transcriptional
level and help better understand also
the molecular basis as highly
customizable platform additional targets
of interest can be easily integrated and
custom research panels can be designed
allowing the relative gene expression
data to it to be obtained for selected
targets from the same sample
to enhance our data analysis for
quantitative plex two software options
are freely available through connect the
term official scientific cloud-based
platform providing streamlined data
analysis with an improved and easy to
follow workflow and also the possibility
for advanced data visualization
as shown here is an example of a
publication in the journal of
immunotherapy of cancer where quantity
impacts custom research panel was used
for gene expression profile analysis in
the pre-clinical discovery and
development of a novel human monoclonal
antibody that binds to the checkpoint
ligand pdl-1
to evaluate the effects of this antibody
high content molecular analysis were
performed on cell lysis from mixed
leukocyte reactions as depicted by the
volcano plot in the upper left as well
as on tumor tissues collected from
several xenograft mouse tumor models as
illustrated by the plot on the upper
right analysis of in both models
revealed a prominent and enhanced t-cell
response upon addition of this blocking
antibody consistent with interferon
gamma pathway and t-cell
activation furthermore when uh comparing
single agent treatment versus the
combination of pdl1 and ctla4 antibody
treatment as shown in the venn diagram
below
some overlap but also unique patterns
were observed with gene expression
changes indicative of immune activation
for single antipdl1 treatment
enhanced t cell activation in response
to single anti-ctla fault treatment
and the further up regulated th1 type
response upon combination
so overall this highlights how
quantitative flex assets can effectively
support evaluation of potential novel
immunotherapies
demonstrating the ability of this
antibody to effectively block the pdl1
pd1 axis to drive more effective
anti-tumor t-cell immunity
we furthermore continued to expand our
portfolio of multiplex for carterblex
panels for protein expression studies in
the cancer research field to offer the
most flexible solution and the
comprehensive collection of markers that
ultimately enables the systematic
analysis of relevant targets addressing
all hallmarks of cancer as shown here
and as originally summarized in previous
publications by hanahan and weinberg
in addition to readily available
multiplex brocardoplex assays for
protein targets implicated in cancer
hallmarks evading growth suppressors
inducing angiogenesis
resisting cell death and evading immune
destruction and tumor promoting
inflammation we put a particular
emphasis on covering now also the
hallmark's sustained cell prol
proliferative signaling and invasion and
metastasis by providing more than 30 new
targets to researchers supporting in the
studies of these aspects as well which
are
among the fundamental features of cancer
cells enabling invasive growth
capabilities and driving a tumor
progression
in previous years the main focus was on
a soluble immune checkpoint regulators
by providing in total three immune
oncology checkpoint marker procartiplex
panels that were the first of their kind
in the marketplace at that time and that
are now combined in one immune
checkpoint 37 plex procartaplex panel
covering all a relevant soluble
checkpoint molecules for immuno-oncology
research
among the key cancer research areas
immuno-oncology has rapidly evolved as a
field that provides several promising
strategies on targeted modulation of an
individual's immune system to combat
cancer this includes and involve
involves cancer vaccines so that
stimulate immune response is based on
antigens and neoantigens released by
cancer cells upon cell death car t cell
therapy that further expands the
adaptive cell transfer as well as immune
checkpoint inhibition as an approach
based on therapeutic antibodies that
target immune checkpoint pathways as a
way to attack cancer cells
immune checkpoint pathways are crucial
in balancing immune responses however
can also be dysregulated and used by
cancer cells as a mechanism to finally
evade immune surveillance
immunotherapies using immune checkpoint
inhibitors to block the effects of
pd1 or ctla-4 were among the first to
market with several antibodies that have
already been approved or are currently
in clinical trials
so since the nobel prize in 2018 for the
discovery of cancer therapy based on
inhibition of negative immune regulation
via ctla4 and pd1
investigation of checkpoint pathways has
progressed and continues to target
immune checkpoint markers also as a
combination therapies and to identify
potential new drug targets and
predictive biomarkers that will
potentially provide important insights
and to further optimize also therapeutic
benefits but also to minimize the risk
of possible side effects of
immunotherapies
so actually the immune checkpoint 37 of
black spruc cartiplex panel is a
powerful tool to help further
investigate immune checkpoint pathway
functionality in effector t cells and
natural killer cells which are involved
in the regulation of both adaptive and
inhibit immunity as it includes the most
important co-stimulatory and
co-inhibitory molecules which are often
engaged by cancer cells to old
activation pathways
and that are particularly involved in
steps three and seven t-cell activation
and killing of cancer cells of the
cancer immunity cycle as schematically
shown in the figure on the left
that you are probably familiar with
summarizing in a seven step process how
the immune system combats uh cancer
each of these seven steps is tightly
regulated and involves not only
checkpoint molecules but also pro and
anti-inflammatory cytokines which are
involved in the regulation of step two
as well as chemokines and adhesion
molecules which regulate the steps four
and five t-cell trafficking and
infiltration
uh which we all cover in our portfolio
of prokartoplex multiplex assays
so in addition to the adaptive t-cell
mediated immunity similar regulatory
processes and checkpoints can also be
found during init immune cell activation
and as pointed out in the figure on the
right a lot of receptor-ligand
interactions of natural killer cells are
also to be explored as potential
therapeutic targets that might mediate
anti-cancer immune responses
so in general for the majority of immune
checkpoint molecules
also soluble isoforms or shed variants
have been described that can act as
decoy receptors or immune adjuvants in
the regulation of checkpoint pathways
and which might also impact the efficacy
of individual checkpoint modulated drugs
therefore immune oncology checkpoint
biomarker procartiplex panels have been
specifically designed and optimized to
measure key soluble analytes in human or
mouse serum plasma and cell culture
supernatant samples
as illustrated by the bar chart on this
slide a screen of more than 70 human
melanoma samples finally confirmed that
all these soluble forms of checkpoint
molecules that are included in the
brocardobrex multiplex panels
are indeed detectable in serum
third evaluation demonstrated that
expression patterns of the soluble
markers are dependent on disease state
and cancer treatment
as depicted by the two graphs a
reduction of pd1 levels was observed in
melanoma samples when comparing early
treatment to pre-treatment resulting in
characteristic responder profiles which
might help to pre-select and better
stratify subjects who may benefit from a
certain treatment
this further highlights that analyzing
all these soluble checkpoint molecules
might provide valuable information on
early treatment responses
to also support pre-clinical and
translational research studies on the
response to potential therapeutic
treatment in mouse models specific
soluble receptors and ligands are
combined into mouse immune oncology
checkpoint brocardo black cell panels
which have been evaluated by a
collaborator in normal and tumor tissues
as shown here in the two bar charts
analysis of in total 11 analytes in
tumor tissue extracts from non-treated
and treated mice revealed a distinct
protein profile with differentially
expressed proteins in the treated versus
the control group suggesting a role for
these proteins in tumor progression
to further elucidate the interplay of
tumor cells and the tumor micro
environment to better understand the
complexity of cancer exploring all
facets of the immune system is key and
as outlined here on this slide this
network involves a multitude of cells
and other soluble factors such as
chemokines and cytokines besides immune
checkpoint molecules that regulate and
shape local and systemic immune
responses which can be either cancer
promoting or cancer suppressive and
overall depend on the critical balance
between stimulatory and inhibitory
mediators
thus analysis of a broader set of
immunomodulatory markers is of great
interest
to get an even more complete picture of
an individual's immune status which
might help to also gain better
understanding of therapeutic benefit and
resistant mechanisms
the immune monitoring human brocadoplex
panel as shown here is actually the
largest available panel on this
multiplex platform enabling efficient
analysis of immune response profiles by
simultaneous measurement of 65 cytokine
chemokine and growth factor targets in a
single well
it is a furthermore complement that also
by an intuitive cloud-based software
solution with the new procartoplex
analysis app that features 4pl and 5pl
curve feed optimization and enables
graphical data analysis including group
wise statistical and heat map analysis
and the possibility for a publication
quality export of data
in a recent publication as cited here
immuno-oncology checkpoint human
brocardo panel and the cytokine
chemokine and growth factor 45 plex
human brocardoplex panels were used
to determine baseline levels of in total
59 chemokines cytokines and soluble
immune checkpoint molecules in plasma
samples of a discovery cohort before
treatment with a pd1 inhibitor to
evaluate response to immunotherapy
and based on a calculated signature
score as displayed by the heat map a
correlation between the distribution
pattern of these soluble factors and the
potential therapeutic benefit was
retrospectively explored in different
subgroups
as shown in the scatter scatterplots
below distinct patterns could be
identified for three targets
while a decreasing trend of therapeutic
response was observed for al-10 across
the subgroups significantly increased
pre-treatment levels were identified for
ccl5 oriontes and pdl1 and their
relevance as biomarkers for efficient
immunotherapy further confirmed in a
validation cohort as shown by the
scatterplots below
so high expression of these two proteins
as a so-called two cytokine signature
was found to be associated with
increased disease control rate and
survival
underscoring the predictive value of
these targets for the stratification of
individuals who may benefit from a
certain treatment
so this is an example where two
pre-configured brocartoplex multiplex
panels one for human monitoring and one
immuno oncology checkpoint biomarker
panel were efficiently combined to
support cancer research
as previously mentioned a more recent
focus was set on the cancer hallmark
sustained proliferative signaling
now offering a prokartoplex multiplex
panel with
eight target proteins that are
implicated in the regulation of cell
proliferation and growth
and favoring cell growth and survival
with uncontrolled and continuous
proliferation
finally paves the way for another
hallmark of cancer which is invasion and
metastasis with two additional multiplex
panels including in total 25 proteins
that are associated with
cancer progression and metastatic spread
when looking at the cardinal embryonic
antigen as one of the key targets
benchmark testing of the procartiplex
research assay to a commonly used ibd
allies of another supplier using 32
tumor and controlled samples
demonstrates a good correlation as
depicted in the plot on the left
with detectable levels and elevated
signals for confirmed
cea-positive samples compared to
controls as shown in the graph on the
right
besides the cardinal embryonic anti-chan
the performance of prokartoplex research
assets for two further cancer antigens
as shown here was evaluated in tumor
versus control samples in comparison to
established assays that are routinely
used to detect these tumor markers
um to monitor cancer progression but
also the effectiveness effectiveness of
cancer treatment
benchmark testing of the procartiplex
essays showed for both cancer and the
chance good correlation to uh this ibd
uh elisa's as depicted in the plots on
the right underscoring the excellent
performance of the procartaplex assay so
for both
cancer antigens
another important feature of cancer is
resistance to cell death that is often
associated also with the defective
removal of apoptotic cells and debris
so while the apoptotic cell clearance uh
procartaplex panel includes 12 relevant
proteins that are involved in the
process of apherocytosis the cell that
multiplex panel now uh combines further
relevant protein markers
that are released into the micro
environment upon cell stress such as
danger associated molecular patterns
or in response to anti-cancer therapy
induced cell death
such as hmg b1
and when analyzing human breast cancer
samples before and after chemotherapy
using human multiplex brocardoplex
panels as demonstrated by the box plots
of the previous publication
the levels of soluble checkpoint markers
cd27 cd80 and pdl2 correlated with hmgb1
levels and were increased in human
samples with a better response to new
adjuvant chemotherapy and a better
five-year survival
these findings suggest that the immune
status differs between individuals with
increased hmg b1 levels in response to
chemotherapy as compared to those
individuals without increase and further
underscores their value and relevance of
detecting these markers to better
develop and design treatment strategies
addressing the cancer hallmark uh
evading growth suppressors and for
studying this particular aspect the
growth factor human 11 plex pro
cardoplex panel is readily available
and has been used as referenced here in
a study
to analyze some angiogenic growth
factors in supernatants of micro tissues
which revealed a differential secretion
profile particularly for vgfa fgf2 and
pdgfpb
in distinct cancer co-culture models
that were finally selected to develop a
3d model to study tumors and to provide
a
model and
for functional screening of
anti-angiogenic
drugs
for in-depth uh studies of angiogenesis
uh which is a prerequisite for cancer
progression two additional angiogenesis
human brocadoplex multiplex panels are
pro available
now to provide
uh additional uh relevant targets uh
that can be simultaneously detected to
further explore this aspect
and in recent studies cited here the
angiogenesis human uh prokartaplex 18
plex panel
was performed on supernatant fluids to
determine changes in the protein profile
of extracellular vesicles released from
lash mania infected cells versus
extracellular vesicles from control
cells
to obtain a final insight into possible
functions of hostile proteins that are
preferentially released into
extracellular vesicles from leishmania
infected cells
and as depicted by the bar charts the
significantly increased levels were
found for particular mediators such as
il-8 and the angiogenic factors
including pdegf
bb
gcsf
or also amprene in extracellular
vesicles from infected cells that have
been shown to promote angiogenesis and
alter tissue vascularization in a way
that favors a lesion development
this brings me directly to the role of
exosomes which are the smallest
extracellular vesicles that originate
from multivesicular compartments of the
endocytic pathway
and
there is growing interest in the role of
exosomes as key mediators of cell to
cell communication particularly in the
context of cancer which has accelerated
considerably within recent years
exosomes that can derive also from a
tumor
a cell or a tumor micro environment and
their cargo
are increasingly acknowledged as
valuable source of biomarkers associated
with essentially all of the described
hallmarks of cancer that might be
indicative of a disease state or
processes such as metastatic spread
and besides
their role as a potential predictive
marker might serve also as potential
therapeutic targets or vehicles for
anti-cancer drugs
as there is not a single exosome
specific marker the exosome
characterization human procataplex panel
has been designed including six selected
to target proteins as listed in the
table on the left
covering all relevant categories of
proteins to demonstrate the nature and
purity of exosome preparations in line
with the recommendations of the
international society for as
extracellular vesicles as summarized on
the right
these include typical tetra spanish such
as cd81 cd63 and cd9 and integrin as
additional transmembrane protein
syntholine 1 representative for
cytosolic proteins recovered in
exosomes as well as cytochrome c as a
control for proteins associated with
other intracellular compartments
in addition the upper lipoprotein human
brokartaplex multiplex panel is readily
available to also control for
non-vesicular structures that are
commonly co-isolated with extracellular
vesicles including apoa or apob as
outlined on the right
so as shown in the graphs on this slide
uh when evaluating the performance uh
with a serial dilutions of large
exosomes isolated either from serum as
indicated in red
or from conditioned media of a human
melanoma cell line as indicated in black
it was demonstrated
detectable levels and the good linearity
for each of the targets except for
cytochrome c that serves as control for
proteins associated with other cellular
compartments as mentioned and this
indicative of the purity of exosome
preparations so as expected uh signals
were below the detection range for
purified exosomes while a whole cell
lysate here indicated in orange served
as positive control and revealed high
detectable levels
instead
besides these targets for exosome
characterization
a number of kinds of biomarkers have
also been identified as exosome derived
being present on the surface or within
exosomes uh in addition to the secreted
soluble forms
and uh uh one of these targets is
cardinal embryonic and the chan which
which has been um verified for this
particular sample matrix using the
brocartoplex assay
uh biotitrating exosomes isolated from
conditioned media of a cea positive
colorectal cancer cell line as depicted
in the two plots on the right showing a
detectable levels and
excellent linearity with an r square of
0.9
apart from um the cardinal embryonic
antigens many of the cancer research
targets available on the multiplex
procatoplex panels as presented have
been identified as exosomal cargo as
outlined in the table showing just a
representative list of relevant targets
and in addition to pre-configured panels
our mix-and-match offering provides the
highest flexibility of customized
combinations also of these available
targets and the relevant cancer research
targets to design a unique panel uh with
their own analyte composition
appropriate respective
research needs
so this allows to exploit cancer direct
exosomes and their unique molecular
composition and protein composition
in order to obtain an even more complete
profile of cancer immunity
so to conclude our portfolio of xmap
technology based in literature multiplex
assays provides a unique solution for
biomarker profiling in cancer research
by introducing new protein assets
on the procataplex platform for markers
particularly involved in metastasis cell
proliferation cell death and the
characterization of exosomes that can
also be combined with markers involved
in immuno-oncology angiogenesis and
apoptosis
so i hope i have given you some
important insights into these powerful
tools for comprehensive analysis of gene
and protein markers to advance your
cancer research thank you for your
interest in this presentation
thank you dr rodrina for your important
informative presentation we will now
start the q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen now let's get started
our first question is can i stay with my
established exosome isolation method
when using the exosome characterization
panel or other ppx assays for exosomal
protein cargo analysis
well yes yes of course uh established
and commonly used exosome isolation
protocols and procedures such as auto
centrifugation size exclusion
chromatography or filtration methods can
be used for
for preparing exosome samples that are
to be subjected for analysis on these
multiplex assays
and
we also offer a range of tools and
products for isolation of exosomes and
their rna and protein content such as
precipitation reagents that are
available for serum plasma
cell culture media and others or the the
total exosome rna and protein isolation
kits to
to recover exosomal protein cargo also
for further downstream analysis that
have also been used
for exosome sample preparations in the
evaluation of these
multiplexer assays and
have been included as a recommendation
also in the in the user guide that comes
with this broker flex multiplex panels
thank you for that
our next question um you mentioned a
unique ready to use 384 well format for
ppx essays is this available for any
panel
um so well this uh in addition in
addition to uh the liquid formulation of
of premixed bead sets that are commonly
provided in a single while this is this
is really an exclusive format for the
pocateplex assay with pre-dispensed
levelized beats in the 384 belt plate
which
eliminates also the the beat
dispensation step in the in the sa
workflow and
at the same time of course minimizes
speed dispensation errors and means less
hands-on time and less time to result
and this is actually provided um
especially for our largest panels on
this multiplex platform which is the
immune monitoring
human 65 plex brocartoplex panel the
cytokine chemokinen growth factor 45
plex human procartaplex panel as well as
the the human
monitoring a mouse of 48 plex pro carter
flex panels
but
we provide custom services for
immunoassays in general if there are any
special requests or requirements in this
regard
oh thank you for that sorry i was on
meat um
another question we have coming in can
immuno oncology checkpoint multiplex
assays be combined with certain cytokine
targets
so yes indeed so besides combining um
two pre-configured panels as shown in
the presentation where an immune
oncology checkpoint multiplex panel and
the cytokine chemokine and growth factor
45 blacks panel were used to cover all
relevant targets of interest
our mix and match uh panels um can can
be easily designed with with the choice
of of targets using
our panel configurator and selection
tool on our website
providing high flexibility and highest
flexibility to to design a panel of
choice
also for desired species different
sample types so really appropriate to
the research needs
perfect thank you again and as a
reminder for the audience if you have
any questions please go ahead and submit
them now
we have good great questions coming in
another one can i also look at gene
expression using luminex technology if
so how many targets can i analyze in one
well
right so there are two as mentioned two
different applications uh provided um
that make use of the luminex technology
for protein but also for for gene
expression studies and the quantity
simplex assays in particular allowed to
easily measure rna
with up to 80 genes of interest
including housekeeping genes that
can be selected from from really a large
inventory of more than 20 000 genes and
are available also in 96 or 384 will
format providing highest sample
throughput and if there is a particular
gene of interest
as mentioned as highly customizable
platform also custom research panels can
be usually provided
in in a couple of weeks within three
three weeks
thank you and another question we have
which luminex instrument do i need for
these panels and where can i get them
so
we
you can use
the all kinds of luminix instruments um
so um the the latest uh
intelliflex instrument is uh the most
advanced one um
but uh depending on on the yeah the the
need and the the lab space
different instruments fit for um for
different uh applications and and needs
uh but the luminex instruments are
provided also
um
[Music]
by us so yeah
great thank you we have time for just a
couple more questions
um i someone say i'm interested in a
particular protein target but no ppx
assay is available are there further
assays to come
so
yeah
in general we continuously expand our
portfolio of available targets for for
our multiplex assays but also other
immunoassa platforms
and offer a collection of markers that
um include well-established but also
novel emerging targets of interest in
various areas that is not limited to
cancer research if there is still a
target of interest which which can't be
found in our portfolio
we offer also custom essay development
service for unique targets on all
available immunoassay platforms so in
this case um you're welcome to contact
us for a free consultation
great thank you it looks like we have
time for about one more question
and do you have data analysis tools
yes indeed so
tools for improved data analysis are
available for for both multiplex asset
platforms um via the connectors or
cloud-based platform of thermofish
scientific
for quantity ginplex assays um the
quantitative analysis software is
available and data can also be exported
into the transcriptome analysis console
that allows for more advanced analysis
also graphical data output and for a
protein expression as a prokartoplex
platform also an analysis app is now
available
that improves
the data analysis workflow and also
offers advanced options heat map group
wise statistical analysis
great thank you again dr rodrina for
your time today and your important
research before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions i'd also
like to thank our sponsor luminex for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions we do not have time for today
or those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact contact information you
have provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years till october of 2023
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time
thank you goodbye